Killian Murphy did a major deep dive
into Oppenheimer in order to play his
titular role luckily because he's a
major historical figure there are a ton
of Articles books and documentaries for
him to devour he describes his method of
getting into character as going from the
outside in well you know we really
wanted to get silhouette right in the
voice right and the physicality right he
worked very closely with the hair makeup
and costume Department as well as
Christopher Nolan to make sure the
character he depicted on the screen was
the one they both wanted oppenheimer's
character as well as the entire film is
basically a collaborative process
between Christopher Nolan and Killian
Murphy two of them together watching
them build this character it's why the
whole movie works yeah